ja uns über die aktuellen entwicklungen
kann ich nun sprechen mit dem virologen
jürgen russland vom uniklinikum ohne
klinikum des saarlandes in homburg guten
tag ich bin wieder fit ja das ist ja die
fortsetzung des albtraum ist jedenfalls
für mich dieses neue virus was da
offensichtlich ja jetzt in südafrika
entdeckt worden ist was weiß man denn
über b115 29
als zunächst erst mal dass ein neues
virus auftritt ist jetzt nicht völlig
ungewöhnlich und das erschreckt
eigentlich erst mal die welt innerhalb
der fachleute gar nicht so sehr
natürlich nimmt man das ernst natürlich
wird man das prüfen müssen was daraus
erwächst aber das ist eben immer
grundsätzlich vorkommen kann dass lag
eigentlich auf der hand corona viren
mutieren die alle anderen rna viren auch
das heißt sie verändern ihre praktisch
ab substanz punkt pro portion sind dass
einzelne nur elemente werden
ausgetauscht das läuft ständig ab und
das ist bei influenza bei dem echte
grippe virus genauso beim humanen
immundefizienz virus genau das gleiche
in grün zur krone wir haben einen großen
vorteil sie mutieren etwas weniger
häufig als die anderen beiden erreger
gruppen über gesagt haben und insofern
muss man ein bisschen abwarten ob das
jetzt hinausläuft wie funktioniert denn
die entstehung von solchen neuen
varianten oder neuen mutationen ist das
an bestimmte bedingungen geknüpft
es ist erstmal zu fall sehr viel zufall
im spiel und in der regel sind die
mutationen die dann am ende auch
wirklich raus kommen weil sie die
mutierten varianten eigentlich in der
regel immer mit einer schlechteren
überlebenschance
verbunden verbunden das heißt also es
passiert nicht automatisch immer eine
frau aus menschlicher sicht betrachtet
verschlimmerung der situation sondern
der regel eigentlich sind die neuen
varianten weniger ansteckend weniger
effektiv in der übertragung auch weniger
auch krank machende das heißt eben es
ist für uns eigentlich relativ
unbedeutend aber inzwischen all diesen
für uns aus unserer menschlichen sicht
positiven varianten ausbildung gibt halt
immer wieder auch solche die eben für
die menschen negativ sein können also
aggressiver werden können und genau das
gilt es jetzt zu beobachten wir wissen
seit dem 11 november gibt es eben diese
erste beobachtung dieser neuen variante
in botswana jetzt eben haben die
kollegen aus aus südafrika eben gestern
in der pressekonferenz weitere
informationen eben mitgeteilt momentan
ist die gesamte fachwelt eigentlich
drauf und analysiert und guckt aber wir
können zum jetzigen zeitpunkt noch nicht
definitiv abschätzen was daraus erwächst
wir wissen eigentlich derzeit nur ja
sind ein paar mutation mehr in dieser
neuen variante drin aber ob die sich
wirklich auch so richtig zum negativen
für den menschen auswirken das wird mir
noch beobachten müssen jetzt geht es ja
um die frage wie reagieren die
impfstoffe auf dieses neue virus oder
auf diese neue variante wie lang dauert
denn sowas bis man weiß ob die
impfstoffe wirken oder nicht also das
wird man jetzt in den ländern die
stärker betroffen sind natürlich relativ
schnell zumindest ansatzweise beurteilen
können das problem an der geschichte ist
südafrika ist ein land das auch noch
eine relativ überschaubare impfquote hat
größenordnung etwa 23 prozent
und auch in botswana wo jetzt praktisch
der erste befund war auch die kollegen
dort unten liegen eben erst bei knapp 20
prozent das heißt also da kann man eben
sehr schlecht die wirkungen wirklich
definitiv beurteilen
man wird es versuchen eben mit
zellkultur versuchen dann wird eben
gucken ob die die iren in zellkultur
versuchen eben von den jetzt schon
bekannten antikörper
die man eben durch impfungen bildet
immer fix neutralisiert werden das kann
man eben machen allerdings muss man
immer auch ein bisschen im hinterkopf
haben dass die zellkultur versuche nicht
zu 100 prozent in die realität
übertragen sind einfach weil es in der
realität eben auch noch der ganze reihe
von anderen einflussfaktoren gibt wie
beispielsweise das alter eben auch
nachlassende immunität ganz
unterschiedliche menschen betroffen sein
können solche die entweder ungeimpft
sind sollte die unvollständig geimpft
sind solche die zwar vollständig geben
sind aber noch keine booster impfung
haben oder auch solche die jetzt
wirklich schon auch die booster impfung
bekommen haben also das muss alles ein
bisschen insgesamt betrachtet werden das
heißt nicht dass ich das jetzt auf die
leichte schulter nehme aber ich will
jetzt auch nicht in anführungszeichen
den teufel an die wand malen ich glaube
das muss man eben auch sehen wir haben
erstmal eine positive botschaft für uns
auch schon mitnehmen können alle unsere
pc atteste scheinen das irgendwie dieses
neue die neue variante auch erkennen zu
können das heißt also auch die
diagnostik als solche funktioniert
weiter das halte ich erstmal für ein
ganz positives momentum ja und offenbar
herr dr is land funktioniert ja auch die
internationale kommunikation
jedenfalls habe ich heute gehört dass
die südafrikaner sehr schnell die den
rest der welt sozusagen informiert haben
vielen dank bis hierher wir reden ja
gleich nochmal weiter danke bis hierhin